nicolas hulot se rappelle au bon
souvenir des candidats à la
présidentielle dix d'entre eux ont signé
son pacte écologique mais
l'environnement est depuis son retrait
de la course à la présidentielle
redevenu selon lui un sujet parmi
d'autres alors qu'il devait devrait être
le sujet à partir duquel toute
l'organisation de nos sociétés modernes
sera redéfinie bénédicte doré nicolas
hulot nommé conseiller à bruxelles sur
les questions de climat et d'énergie
une reconnaissance européenne alors
qu'en france un mois après la signature
du pacte écologique
les candidats semblent l'avoir un peu
oublié je suis juste étonnée que compte
tenu de ce qu'ils ont signé cette
préoccupation cette réflexion cet enjeu
soit diluée au point quasiment de
disparaître dans toutes leurs
interventions publiques
il ya une forme d'incohérence qui mérite
interrogations en clair maintenant que
10 candidats ont signé son pacte
l'écologie a disparu des programmes
électoraux et pour les candidats et
collants la faute à qui la faute à hulot
il ne l'a pas rendu du tout service à
l'écologie politique je pense qu'il a je
dirais énormément affaibli il a fait
prendre conscience que nous pouvions
mettre en place cette politique mais en
même temps il a rassuré tout le monde
et quand on rassure tout le monde n'a
plus un sentiment d'urgence et donc on
laisse faire la conséquence de ce qu'il
a fait en faisant signer à tout le monde
quelque chose de très light c'est de
tuer carrément l'écologie politique en
france
et avec cette attitude de surcroît de
relatif mépris à l'égard des candidats
qui défendent l'environnement depuis 25
ans comme moi même
eh bien il a accrédité l'idée que
finalement seuls comptaient les grands
partis les grands partis se foutent de
l'environnement on le savait avant et on
le sait après l'animateur de télévision
aurait-il donc décrédibiliser l'écologie
en tant que parent si aujourd'hui
dominique voynet est crédité d'à peine
1% alors qu à la dernière présidentielle
les verts ont obtenu plus de 5% des
suffrages
de quoi avoir quelques rancoeurs même si
elle menace
son ami nicolas hulot fait que les états
majors des partis est considéré qu'ils
étaient quittes avec ce sujet qui peut
passer à autre chose et servir tour à
tour d'autres clientèles qui leur
demandait le contraire des engagements
qu'ils avaient pris ne me paraît pas
être dans le bon sens nicolas hulot lui
compte bien reprendre la main médiatique
il appelle toutes les associations
environnementales à se rassembler le 1er
avril prochain au trocadéro